oh i'd like to celebrate with my wife
because my wife has
been one of my biggest supporters
through such struggle and so many years
of
almost 30 years of struggling in show
business
and so my wife
is still here with me and that is
amazing and so we're going to celebrate
together tonight for sure
[Music]
i'd really like to
make sure that the audience is able to
see a different
perspective rather than a limited window
i'd like to stretch their perception
[Music]
it's my favorite thing
what are you doing next year working
with my dad
i was 17 years old i watched children of
a lesser god and it inspired me
and it really increased my expectations
that i would be able to
work as an actor
and it took forever and it took a lot of
struggling it took 28 years
to finally have a death male role
happens to be death himself
and so i believe that marley
she knew
that there were a lot of deaf talent out
there
but hollywood wasn't paying attention to
them
and they were thinking inside the box so
marley
started thinking outside of the box and
they brought me in and that led us to
this moment and it's been an amazing
journey from the beginning to end
and now we're here at this point
everyone has to make some sacrifices
[Music]
and that authenticity
just was emphasized
and so folks out there can finally
realize that
this is how it should be
and it's a similar concept
a white actor
playing the role of martin luther king
for example
and so would it be appropriate for a
white actor to portray a black character
and it's similar to
a hearing actor portraying a deaf
character on screen but i've seen it
over and over again throughout the years
unfortunately and so finally we got the
right director the right producers
the right story and everything lined up
the stars alive
and so when i was cast for this role
i've noticed this transformation
and
you can notice the difference and folks
in the audience can really feel the
impact of being able to have a different
perspective on deaf people if you know
what i mean and so
it's been a big step forward for
everyone to
be able to experience different
perspectives and now as far as the
second step forward i'm not sure what
it's going to be but it's extremely
exciting and it's an important message
that when you see a film like sound of
metal or coda it's a positive message
for everyone